environmental lawyer phil pothen doesn't
own a car on purpose he's long advocated
for a shift away from car culture as if
we needed another wake-up call pandemic
trends like remote work and virtual
meetings have some segments of society
rethinking things like daily commutes
and in-person business trips that means
using your zoom using your
get your web conferencing if you can do
that or taking a bike if you can do that
to get to work or public transit the
crisis in ukraine is also forcing a
re-evaluation of the world's reliance on
russia the second largest gas producer
and third largest oil producer a
critical step according to this
environmental activist but what this
conflict clearly shows is how dangerous
our dependence on a fossil fuel system
is
global gas prices have soared above a
hundred dollars a barrel for the first
time since 2014 tuesday on the heels of
the u.s ban on russian oil russia warned
that a european ban on its fossil fuels
could lead to an unpredictable price
surge and that oil at 300 a barrel or
more could be in the making
analysts say an energy inflation spiral
could squeeze consumers and businesses
and push europe latin america and
eventually north america and china into
a recession
the pembina institute's alberta regional
director says canada needs to urgently
address what he calls the climate crisis
or risk falling further behind in the
global green shift he says china has
already made big moves on that front the
amount of renewable energy production
that's happening there and electric
vehicles is really dramatic
they're becoming a global leader in
these technologies environmentalists say
there's a strong moral and business case
for moving away from fossil fuel
dependence
expanding our reliance on oil and gas
increases our vulnerability it
accelerates climate change the fires and
the floods that were that are already
costing us billions and and displacing
millions of people
worldwide ann gaviola global news
toronto